ظهرت النواه الاولى لغرفه العمليات
المشتركه عام 2006 وجمعت كتائب عز الدين
القسام الذراع العسكريه لحركه حماس وسرايا
القدس الجناح العسكريه للجهاد الاسلامي مع
اندلاع مسيرات العوده على حدود قطاع غزه
عام 2018
توسع التركيبتها واعلن عنها رسميا باسمها
الحلي تضم غرفه العمليات المشتركه 12
جناحا عسكريا وهي كتائب الشهيد عز الدين
القسام سرايا القدس كتائب شهداء الاقصى
كتائب الشهيد عبد القادر الحسيني الويه
الناصر صلاح الدين كتائب المقاومه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه كتائب ابو علي مصطفى كتائب
الشهيد جهاد جبريل كتائب الانصار كتائب
المجاهدين
مجموعات الشهيد ايمن جودي وجيش العاصفه
[موسيقى]
تعتبر غرفه العمليات بمثابه هيئه اركان
يرتكز عملها على التنسيق التحركات
الميدانيه والعملياتيه لفصائل المقاومه
اثناء العمليات العسكريه
وتتولى تحديد طبيعه الرد على هجمات
الاحتلال او اتخاذ قرار بشن عمليات ضده
بعيدا عن المواجهات الفرديه لكل فصيل
نجاحت غرفه العمليات المشتركه في تحييد
التباينات السياسيه بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه لصالح موقف موحد اثناء القتال
تحديدا
وتمكنت الفصائل المنضويه تحت لوائها من
التوافق على التوجهات استراتيجيه لعمل
المقاومه مع الحفاظ على استقلاليه كل فصيل
من حيث الهويه
نهايه عام 2020 نفذت غرفه العمليات مناوره
عسكريه لها سمتها الركن الشديد
وشملت تنفيذ تدريبات بريه وبحريه وجويه
بالذخيره الحيه تحت غطاء الطائرات المسيره
التي حلقت في اجواء القطاع وتخللها اطلاق
صواريخ تجريبيه باتجاه البحر برز العمل
الميداني الفعلي للغرفه المشتركه خلال
عمليه سيف القدس في رمضان عام 2021
اعتبرت العمليه برهان ميدانيا على التطور
النوعي الذي وصلت اليه فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه ان لناحيه تطوير
التقنيات العسكريه او لناحيه تنسيق
المواقف السياسيه فيما بينها
وفي الذكرى الاولى لسيف القدس اصدرت
الغرفه المشتركه بيانا مقتضبا يحمل جمله
لافته تقول ان سيف القدس لم يغمد في اشاره
الى مواصله الفصائل بهذه التجربه في تحيد
التباينات السياسيه عن العمل الميداني